hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
were at the final part here and we are
going forward with it so thank you
everybody so much for being there this
is going to be the very end of the game
and we are going all the way until we
reach the end which means that no matter
how long this game is this stream is
gonna continue until the very conclusion
of this game which will be sad because I
love this game very much but also really
satisfying because I can't wait to get
to the end of its game so I don't think
there's anything else new in here I
don't think there's anything I forgot to
do in terms of inventory besides maybe
craft up some stuff still haven't gotten
any rifle ammo I'm waiting to see if I'm
gonna get any rifle animal out in the
wild but for now we've gotten all of the
projection slides if everyone has looked
into that or if everyone remembers from
the last episode we call to prevent
projection slides all of our friends are
dead except for Jojo who is alive
apparently and trapped in this hellhole
which makes me think that maybe everyone
is alive and trapped in this hellhole
maybe no one ever dies maybe nothing
ever bad happens maybe we're all gonna
be hunky-dory and ok but maybe I also
have enough now I need 20000 just not
enough but maybe I got some stuff here I
can get that smoke upgrade whoo yeah
maybe that's gonna help me perform sneak
kills on enemies caught within the area
effect that might be nice
I don't know they'll be very nice but
it'll be kind of nice ok crafting well
this can we do more smoke bolts why not
yeah shocks bolts sure
explosive bolts why not boom bolts yeah
always Coons
all right frizzy bolts why not these
have been the most useful things or all
of these have been incredibly useful so
I gotta make sure I actually give them
the
they're due I'm gonna wait on ammo cuz I
want to really really really make sure
that I actually used my harpoon because
if I don't do that I'm gonna die cuz I
keep okay I forgot how forgot how well
thing it is out here
alright anybody else in here I guess I
keep going up then no matter what people
tell me
alright I can't reach it I'm not tall
enough
Oh hmm
so do I shoot it Oh as simple as that
okay
I don't know what oh I don't want to
know what happened over there
okay there's cold container and somebody
blew up oh it's in another one of those
[ __ ] oh it is isn't it oh it is
isn't it okay well if I can get if I can
get him
let me see if I can just do the normal
stabby stab it's all I'm interested
there one two
skip to my Lou ow gonna move should move
faster should've known that he was
coming for me
okay you go over here you go Dan I
wonder if he's gonna notice me I'm just
experimenting right now yeah I think I
lost ya okay all right he's shooting at
crazy shoe now yes now who don't know
now he totally lost so I just got to be
very very slow and careful with this guy
oh there are other zombies around cuz he
he just like goes to standstills like
that which is good for me because I can
lose him easily
if no don't that is fast money
Wow okay you're wasting fuel a bit there
but okay
why did you do that Sebastian what the
hell why Sebastian wha via Sebastian why
you why did you stop why Sebastian why
we went through this together for so
long Sebastian
why would you stop oh boy okay alright
let's try this see if this is gonna work
sneak kills sneak there we go
all right one
he's still covered in the smoke so he
didn't even know you still don't know oh
he knows he knows he knows he knows
also he I should probably take a medkit
if I'm actually gonna go forward with
this one all right
[Music]
maybe I don't even need a really fight
of my boo oh that's not good yeah there
we go
are ye oh that's the opposite of good
okay I don't know if I have time for
this I'm on fire Wow
your range on that is stupid ugly I am
trampled oh here we go oh okay I'm dead
well that didn't work out in my favor
stop drop and roll buddy okay so bad
start but also bad on him for being a
dick and bad on Sebastian Castellanos
for not going where he was supposed to
go so now we're gonna get back into it
and I'm not gonna not gonna let him get
a forehead because the farther you go
ahead I guess the more more enemies you
could possibly meet but also I might
just be able to stealth my way through
all this because if I use my silenced
pistol which I do have if I use my
silenced pistol to shoot out these
things for now I'll use this one cuz it
only requires really oh thank you
peculiar if he used whoa what okay
yeah I might actually be able to just
sneak my way past all these
oh not if I do that oh god damn it
okay what's in here toink oh hello I'll
take that thank you it turns off and on
had I oh oh I got the biggest sack yeah
well that guy was ready for the soup and
that guy was ripe for soup I I've goofed
it oh boy oh boy oh boy oh hi hello
friend
oh boy oh boy I am NOT doing this right
wolf you know what what if I what if I
smoke y'all right there don't poke don't
move don't move don't move don't move
you're not native of gun Armenian what
I'll move I'll move and you're moving
out I'm moving you don't know how about
angle okay there we go heyy anything in
this pile no pilot
I see the viola buried over here hmm
this is precarious
I'll Kurt uncle this for no reason
that's not Oh Oh reload reload reload
reload reload reload and shoot that's
not the one I wanted I've got an axe
oh you're you were dead before I wasted
two shots okay well okay all right not
necessary in any okay I'm a run you know
what I'm gonna run get on a run maybe
yeah smartest ideas just for brawn for
it cuz it seems like there's options for
me to run oh oh wait
that was something one is down one it's
down one is down and gun bullets okay
you know it's a freezie over here why
did he go wait is he upstairs way open
when did that open up
smoke BAM
you can't see [ __ ] and I doubt I can
sneaks not kill you okay gone okay all
right I don't know where that would be
all right oh okay for a second I thought
there was a corpse of chat every teen
over there all right well I guess we
gotta go but we can go in here first
just in case all right thanks so the
most effective solution is running away
apparently who does funked what if uncle
bit
who'da thunk all dunked okay is there
any reason we need to be in here I
probably got enough goop to do the
consecutive blammo ah yes please
my combat skills of which I value so
greatly haha yes of course yes I do have
enough okay we're gonna get in this
chair we're gonna sit our button down
there keep our pants a little bit no
we're gonna stab this in our brain
detective Castellanos always a pleasure
to see you of course yes very pleasure
you have anything new to say to me
you're emanating power and confidence
yes I'm close to the end and I've
learned a few things I just want to take
care of this once and for all
indeed I do provide you with some help
but but what you must be cautious you
have overcome challenges but too much
certainty can be dangerous hmm he will
prey on you using the darkest corners of
your mind then I'd better get ready okay
but wait where you said you were gonna
help me there's nothing wrong with are
you gonna help me oh shut up but you
can't avoid I didn't shut up okay yes
for a set amount of time shooting damage
is increased with each consecutive shot
that is successfully hits an enemy good
for those bullets
I suppose okay I got that if we're good
we're good we're good but let's get out
of here go go go go go go go go go go go
go
Hey hello hi you didn't miss anything I
was perfect I was amazing I didn't run
away screaming like a baby welcome to
the stream it's gonna be great okay so
what I need to do now is more shock
bolts I think I've got so many fuses so
I might as well load up those are useful
smoke Bam's are useful wondering while
is gonna do with all that flour I've
been picking up these are useful boon
bolts one more there playing pipes yeah
I may have missed all the ammo from the
bodies that I skipped over but also I
didn't waste any ammo trying to kill
anybody so I think I'm in a net plus
here
alright let's hop in this bad boy
alright show me what you got we want
some smoke in their face and then me to
run away screaming
let me also hey I know you got your a
deuce on
just shoot up real quick why that's a
little extreme
that doctor him not if I kill you first
I'll keep coming back to one of us is
dead
oh this is the boss fight oh well I'm
ready to kick your ass I got a lot of
Poon's baby
oh look even another one over here I
shouldn't have made that other one oh
well what a waste
all right what do we got for me ooh what
is a fuse gunpowder er all right okay
I'll be right in there the Theodore are
you wait up just a second I got a guy
see some things over here got check you
know do some stuff got a lot of prunes
she's gotta know when to use and you
know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying he knows you
know and if it's a boss fight aren't
they gonna feed me ammo or somethin
hello Theodore will Punk right there
should have been sittin should have been
sittin down if it's a taste of despair
you wish a taste of despair you shall
receive okay
due to Ryan Davis not shoot you didn't
see me shoot right Ned right in the face
it's all an illusion you right in the
face
kicker give her a girl good old whomp
it's okay sweetie
I'm gonna make it right again
[Music]
and then kick I love you so much Lily oh
I always have also that approach my
works will oh I'm gonna save you this
time oh it's beautiful
it's beautiful my suggestions were
terrible you shouldn't follow my advice
at all
I see you've overcome some of your guilt
and pain whew but the depth of your past
traumas is vast hmm I know everything
about you I know what lies beneath what
about your you're passed away you have a
deep well of fear from which to draw
oh no not mannequins you've seen many
Horrors and they still haunt your
memories remember where this all began
remember beacon okay
yes you remember it all uh-huh okay Oh
No
Oh Garrett I'm running no need to tell
me twice
I'm not looking whoa hey he's right
there okay all right good thing I know
how to do that lady I got unlimited
stamina hula dude I'm not running
anymore
what
enough of this [ __ ] yeah
this Oh God oh what a souping of
subproblems
oh god that was tactical soup delivery
oh what a smarty oh okay oh yes we'll
stop me oh yes please
oh yes please the deluxe super 9000 Oh
capable of delivering every variety of
soup
[Music]
Oh check it dude
yeah Theodore might not want to [ __ ]
with me [ __ ] yeah Theodore probably
should be a little scared by now
whose Oh box head box head you know what
I don't think Oh wolf speeding all right
wait I saw something to use I didn't see
what it was there though oh I remember
this boss fight I do
wait oh you got past me I don't know why
or how yeah wait let's see what a shock
bolt remember correctly come on come at
me bro that does next to nothing oh it
just makes him stop okay hang on I'm
gonna collect supplies and then I'm
gonna come back to you you see if a
smoke bomb will work on
oh hey wait hang on are you unaware are
you unaware
oh he's aware he's aware he's very aware
okay that doesn't work on him all right
good news good to know good know it's
knowledge is power you know what I mean
whoa whoa what the [ __ ] no don't do
that
ooh what is that all about
can I Wang doodle you Wang oh that's not
where territory womp
methinks it may be his character model
isn't built for this kind of stuff all
right how about good old regular that
did him good Oh down for the counter
wolf that's armor right in the heart oh
oh
all right oh yeah he's just gonna get up
from another one I forgot about that
which one of you I'm enough room
bro that's unfair that's what I would
call unfair shouldn't waste cells on me
okay you know what I'm not happy with
you much slice dice what
Oh Ally shrugged that off oh no I
consumed another one a year okay
are ye okay
there you go boy here we go oh boy
I forgot that there was a point where I
face two of these guys all right let me
just do the old-fashioned Shogun to the
face Oh bullet cascade was in fact oh
boy
oh there we are no ammo that's no good
that bullet cascades kind of cool okay
yeah good thing I got all those skills
that make me not die
those are awfully nice well I'm gonna
soup that box don't melee bosses what
are you talking about guys I have to
melee bosses
Oh bye okay see ya all right well I will
do it okay so what they're saying
plum flambe why is that not flambe that
was supposed to flambé all right what I
need is good old shocker oh I had it
where oh not there where's the pipeline
right where is this pipes right here so
I got to keep them right here oh no I
got to turn up all the that's right I
got to get her here and then I got what
because this won't activate just yet I
got to turn on the pipes to get those
started yeah so anyway noodle this
oh okay flame power are you coming
reload I shot a shot I shot a shot where
shut that was a regular pool why is this
okay stay right there stay right there
stay right there oh god damn it why is
there another one oh there's enough oh
I'm not enough time not enough time mama
it's gonna go ahead and say is Nona let
me try to breathe her oh you're very
nearby okay that didn't last at all
about smoke bomb you don't know what's
going on I'm in secret oh god she knows
yep that's me going so low BOM don't
work good to know I burned you once I
wanted to pick up the shock bolt not
that Sebastian Castellanos
let me try that again I give up I'm not
gonna be able to Oh lame throw oh that
be smart no I'm not gonna do it no I
don't need it plain throw the crunch
that's we're bad that's where people who
can't play the game right that's what
that's all about
if you think I'm gonna use the
flamethrower you can get out if you
think I even care about the plan throw
the answer is no I'm gonna do this the
old-fashioned way
you see see what I'm talking about you
see what I'm talking about this called
it's called skill oh boy let's call it
the skill here this called skill you
guys wouldn't know anything about it
yeah guys it probably seen it before any
other gamers such as me well I guess
that I has all the skill that I am
incorporating into my normal everyday
routine good good good exactly what I
wanted okay exactly what I want to stay
right there stay right there
now I'm gonna use the flamethrower now
now would now would be the good time for
that
tamanna sorry what
why is it coming
that is effective
that's supremely effective you know
that's that's incredibly effective I
would say
whoa huh quite quite
ah yeah pretty not good huh are you ah
Sebastian Castellanos you've got miss
purbhani good oh okay Pyrrha good to see
you
Myra she must stay safe I will protect
Lily from anyone who wants to take her
you did it
The Doors dead let's go home
Oh
power of the core is mine
Lily is safe now where is she let's get
her and get out of here
my raw
Myra
Sebastian Sebastian Sebastian Sebastian
Sebastian
I guess souping runs in the family and
Theodore should have known that no
simple soup tactic is gonna take care of
her
Myra she's she's the master of the the
cream-based soup more of a more of a not
VAT soup kind of guy you know the the
chicken and noodle the vegetable with
beef you know not quite the clam
chowder's of the world but that should
we complement each other we complement
each other with we're two halves of the
same whole
she's the the very thick swoops and I'm
the very thin swoops be it are you down
there oh there you are no that's not you
where'd you go Theo Bo Bo you know I
haven't seen a statue in a while but
then again I haven't been looking very
closely for it Oh anyway love that woman
that woman hmm she's the light of my
life
she's the cream of my soup she's Jesus
[ __ ] Shu Yama stop there you know I'm
stopping my stop
all right so I imagine that I'm gonna
have to Matt but I imagine I'm gonna
have to kill her eventually she's gonna
be more tragedy for Sebastian much
there's almost nothing left to this
place yeah no joke there's a black wall
on the Mirage the end of this world oh I
called this video the end of all things
I called yesterday's videos damn deal
all things because I thought yesterday
was gonna be the end oh yeah
alrighty then okay well this is gonna
take a dark turn before or it gets any
sort of better oh boy
oh yeah Oh Myra oh I hate what you've
done with the place
this is way too much goop yeah I would
all wish you would ask
wish you to ask me for some goop advice
I would have whatever told you that it
was just a hair too much goop and I'm
questioning where you got it all but you
know what we'll worry about that later
how did you go yeah Myra you want to
Mayer these Myers are funny joke it's
our humor that keeps us together Myra
through thick and thin you know remember
our vowels you know from when we were
married you remember all those things
yeah that's great cool all right
whatever
Myra a good life map anywhere do you
think I got a map no no map here why
would I have a map
oh well blink blonde coals it's goop oh
oh this is more than goop I don't like
it
Oh Myra Myra Myra don't turn that off
Myra it's over
let's get Lili and leave this place
before we're stuck here forever we can
have our family back
my real face I know you're still in
there you have to listen to me
my rock what's wrong
you gotta fight it I think she is
fighting it I have to protect Lily
already did my Stefano can't hurt her
neither can feed or they're dead yes
good
Sebastian now please why I'm not leaving
you and Lily in this place oh the goop
is that goo purse no I can't quite tell
oh good thing I got good stopping skills
if there's one thing Sebastian is good
at when I'm trying to do something I can
stop dead in his tracks
what is she trying to do isn't it
obvious please heal my emotional wounds
please you have some coffee
I need that please be nice like coffee
nurse I didn't even get any brain
Theodore how may I assist you
I've got emotional trauma please nope
you're facing your worst enemy the one
who you love hmm
I don't understand why she's doing this
her maternal instinct is strong
it's overwhelming her she only remembers
what it is to be a mother it's been too
long since she's been a wife I wish I
could talk some sense into her sometimes
it's difficult to convince the ones you
love of what they refuse to believe you
should understand that more than most I
see what you're saying
just remember that you're doing the
right thing Lily doesn't belong here no
she didn't IRA must understand this
there was still a piece of her somewhere
inside probably not dying
hmm you know they say Chicken Soup for
the Soul so what you're saying is I have
to soup her in the soul is that what
you're saying
blink twice if I'm understanding you
correctly I have no gel I've got nothing
to my name I have nothing
nurse you shut up and get out of here I
don't I don't want to do that she sounds
like a robot oh I wonder why she sounds
like a robot couldn't be because she's
actually stem the system itself looking
to me open me grow as person mm-hmm love
that I'm never gonna get up to like top
level of these I'm just gonna get enough
to get almost and then that way if I
find some in the wild then hopefully it
won't be the worst thing in the world
then I won't hate myself because I
wasted an opportunity to get what I
needed to get okay I think I'm doing my
office wow those blinds went wonky Eddie
dig it here what Joe Joe anybody anybody
oh okay all right kitty buy less cute
now that I know the kitties the nurse
maybe her name is like nurse kitty or
something maybe we can all agree that
that's the name that's too cute for her
nurse kitty yes you know I don't like
that maybe we should change our minds is
it too late to change that course is
that is that ship already sailed
all right
is anything over excuse me
I just had to hug that wall for a second
we're thinking my Barry what was that
Oh guys listen listen guys I I love this
game it has so many quirks it has so
many flaws what is down there
well sorry didn't mean to bust out the
flamethrower but there's some over there
how do I get over there oh there's
something over there how do I get over
there whoa but yeah this this game oh I
see I see I see I see I see I see hot
okay what do I have left I barely any do
I have any gun that has bullets in it
currently other silent okay I like you I
like you but yeah listen I love this
game to death for all its quirks
it is so lovable Leigh this is this is
one of the best games I've played in a
long time as far as it goes to like the
immersive horror shooter genre Resident
Evil 7 was very very good Resident Evil
7 was extremely good don't get me wrong
I loved Resident Evil 7 I'm not saying
this one's better than that this one's a
completely different game besides
there's that one with first-person
shooter this is like a third-person
adventure with a lot more exploration
and a lot more stealth action to it the
other one just was mainly done
but this one god it's so fun like it
also is very self-aware in like the
shooting gallery stuff and like the the
funny quips between the nurse and
sebastian like there's so many like Oh
am I gonna get zombies GUP zombies
GUP zombies goop zombies Oh goob zombies
oh you know it baby oh that's gross
that is so disgusting that is the most
disgusting thing I've ever seen that
might be horrifying
that's B that's bad can i soup them like
I water them down it and I water them
down a bit and get to her okay you keep
doing that I'm gonna see if I can ambush
one of these guys Oh what's with your
foot so so done soup is just as
effective well what was that oh oh you
yeah kind of a strangled cry going on
here okay
that's what are you oh I don't like that
oh the mini hands thing that's a weird
wait wait wait wait wait a minute
oh I don't like that wait remember how
in the theater remember guys in the
theater there he said he found them in
the wild
he didn't make these pieces of art but
he felt it was wrong not to display them
Mayra made all of this probably by
trying to you know kill these zombies
but for now she's just using them but
yeah like that was the whole deal right
remember yeah you remember oh yeah
oh I'm sorry about that
yeah but then so I was kind of right to
smash him up that wasn't that was any of
his doing but that was like that was
like a precursor that was way long how
many more you guys are there please tell
me you're gonna get me some more
supplies with which to stab people from
long range
Furby hello yeah that's so crazy I
didn't even know that was gonna come
into play so the thing about these guys
is oh this is not us
oh that's not a not a hidey hole okay
they're gonna jump down that that was
quite a vertical that you had to
traverse there Sebastian how where to go
where did he go oh you went back okay
he's just looping back and forth between
these two spots um oh there was a box of
medication used I'll just wait for him
to turn around yeah that's so weird
I just remembered that I bet I can burn
him I bet I can but maybe they're
they're wet soupy nature won't allow me
to get a good roast on them all right I
hope she hasn't gone far I mean how far
is there to go there's not much place
left here do I even have nope no map
data no one you know maybe I should tell
Kidman about this maybe maybe Kidman
might want to know something about all
this because there seems to be some uh
some happenings happening in there you
know some some certain some things are
going down and maybe that's Brad shock
bulb is why didn't craft all all up but
they're giving me a lot of good [ __ ] you
know I actually don't want this um I
don't want that gun to be my main one I
really like the full barrel because I
like taking one shot at a time just to
conserve ammo double-barrelled has its
purpose but right now it does not yeah
it's okay keep moving for her get movin
Sebastian you're doing great wait oh I
thought I saw something up there you're
doing great buddy
gave it up love your life going a little
little wonky but you know what that's
okay any other secrets around here any
other Mobius caches know anything down
that alleyway heading down this alleyway
no and no okay negative on both fronts
boom forward
but I love it I feel like you know it's
almost sad that we're approaching Han
because whoa stop my raw come on I've
got soo what if that was just the end of
the game right that's just like a
sandwich right there on Sebastian just
like oh well no QuickTime event oh hello
you on the phone oh no that guy's is
frozen I have time for this
whoa why why did that happen why did
that app why did you stop halfway again
Sebastian gear or Oh got to see that's a
to friend you want some soup do come
closer come closer come closer I got
soup oh you know you know you're we're
okay smoke keep missing
whoa God the soup levels on that bad boy
holy cannoli
holy cannoli do you want to come over
here I got soup oh he's gonna see me
yeah I should heal up but I'm not gonna
just in case if I do die then I'm gonna
start over with higher health oh that
guy is definitely gonna turn into a
Samba
very silent
on a chain these bad boys up Oh ducks in
a row indeed oh oh badass my badass
levels are going up I'll get that one
later oh hell yeah give me full alright
my celebratory get on the box dance at
least I can use that med kit
boink use this one boring key oh no you
don't need to get you don't need to get
on things Sebastian I know you love to
climb but you know just [ __ ] yeah man
and also yeah yeah a lot of people are
saying in the chat like this this game
was like a big part of my history this
first came out in 2004 okay you are def
definitely heard 2004 2014 and so seeing
it come this way because the first game
was good but flawed very flawed but I
loved it despite its flaws like he was
it was diving too hard into a lot of
horror tropes this one it was very like
delicately balanced on the horror tropes
vs the self-aware nature of a hero who
has been through this before like that's
the interesting thing and that's kind of
the take that I liked from dead space 1
I'm going to talk about games furbish
dead space 1 vs. dead space 2 it took a
very good approach and that's why dead
space 3 went wrong
dead space 1 was a person who has never
been through this before was thrown into
a situation with horrible monstrosity
'he's that he didn't know or understand
and and similarly League the game had
the feel of someone who is there Dead
Space 2 took a different approach it
approached it from the perspective to
someone who has been through it
and therefore is suffering from like
post-traumatic stress and also is
familiar with how to kill him like he
knows what's going on so it was a bit
more combat oriented but in a good way
because it balanced it it balanced it
delicately between the pure scares the
self-aware nature and the the horror and
the combat of it all whereas like Dead
Space 3 was almost straight-up combat
and understandably from the perspective
of Isaac who had been through this a
million times already and yes he knows
what's going on but it also didn't take
advantage or didn't Telegraph the other
thing which was what they tried to do
with that co-op mode the other guy had
not been through it before which is why
his co-op story mode was so much scarier
but it wasn't telegraphed like the whole
co-op thing it was just lost and that's
really you're coming with me apparently
Wow you can't get me you can't get me oh
he can get me oh you're not as good a
climber as I am no wing dule you're
right in your face but yeah so it also
there was a lot of other problems with
who he's gonna turn around no he's not
he's not he's nothing he's not
there's a lot of other problems with
Dead Space 3 and what I'm saying is like
this this sequel is about the best
sequel you could possibly hope for from
this for for a sequel that does have you
going back into stem which is the only
place that it could have gone it did it
in such a good way drawing from
inspirations like Silent Hill and other
other subject matters that like like
that you know the early resident evils
and whatnot the slow gathering of like
stuff tons a side quest because I don't
even know if they were there weren't
that many side quests in the first
evil within not that I know of it and
there were tons more and I'm willing
about the ocean board
oh I rock please oh here we go again
[Applause]
you're just taking that with you you're
just taking that with you okay you know
what I don't I don't like that I don't
like that at all trying to shoot that
okay
oh you dickweed okay I can't go that way
all right fine then okay well I'm gonna
get my bearings here hang on a second
sir
places hold on dear luck it's over
thank you
weapons ban Gary that's scary okay why
don't you walk through this thing all I
got to do is like walk it through this
because it's gonna blow that up
it's all I can blow it up okay did not
blow that up I thought it was gonna blow
it up I have to blow that up okay that
wasn't on the same page because last
time it you know it did it did the whole
blow-up thing so I was just assuming
alright I like is he Whangdoodle that
car pretty yard is where you gotta come
by
hey over here but gonna add this on
ready huh little closer burn all that
nothing oh how about Europe
that ain't good why is that an ability
that you have you just took that pole it
shouldn't even have power anymore I mean
that those those capacitors shouldn't be
holding that long
oh boy okay well that's the opposite of
good but maybe I should shoot that thing
how about this closer under a grundle
okay
goddammit you dodgy bastard you dead
tonight
got you something okay no you know I'm a
dig up alright well that didn't work
okay you know what I'm out of here I do
not like you at all
whoa this suckles Mike chuckles I think
I know what spot to aim for but man is
it precocious
you dead oh he's dead
oh he's dead he's down for the count
that was a big boy no I don't think
that's how it's gonna be somewhere did I
lose any supplies over here I think
that's how it's gonna go all right any
other supplies I imagine there's some
Mobius dumps around here somewhere
no empty I hate you oh no you're the
worst okay yeah but anyway so that's
what I was saying about that it's just a
very very interesting take on it and I
appreciate it like extremely I do and
it's like it's rare because these kind
of like single-player only experiences I
feel are being narrowed down into the
more like horror genre whereas
everything else like has multiplayer
components I don't think this game is a
real player component but if it did it
might actually be kind of fun like just
if it was about this exploration I'm not
gonna swear it won't finish your soup
lose I'd never do that I love her your
love can't protect her only I can do
that
told you to leave my rock Chabad ow oh
I'm do your legs those varicose veins
huh
Oh Oh my ride bye hooptie Oh
curious as to why Mayra can do the all
this [ __ ]
what's my superpower in this place
besides soup delivery
all right
I'll break your leg I'm waiting for the
cliche I'm too old for this [ __ ]
well hmm oh that's not good huh I've got
soup Mira's got milk I think that's the
kind of takeaway we should take from
this what is this snow or dandruff I
don't want to know
can't let her take Lily no I can't bear
oh I'm moving slow up no exploration for
me map no communicator no like a desert
of snow oh that's so cool
oh that's so cool is that our house
I don't know I've never seen it before
so oh yes I have it burnt down many
times in my memories she must be there I
can't stop now I could you know I very
much good absolutely good is there a map
no map no okay let's see what's going on
in this surrounding area here because
there's got to be goodies I know there's
got to be goodies right I've made an
error
oh oh no no oh
oh here I go wait I'm gonna get Africa
freedom freedom oh please I'm stuck in
is this the place in stem that people go
to when they died I've made a horrible
error made a grievous mistake I've made
a terrible error oh boy
okay all right then if I can we're
loading an autosave there we go in limbo
there I can't stop now I can stop down
no Motel ceiling will stop be Oh No
bye one weakness or roof ah somebody
shut this roof on fire
please he'll be okay I'm getting down
now apparently did I bet it I love this
game
oh god is good good [ __ ] is that good
[ __ ] right here okay it's fine it's fine
everybody calm down you calm down your
collective tits out there I'm doing just
fine where's a mirror when you need it I
really need to gussy up okay I don't see
any supplies I don't see any surprises I
don't see nothing oh what's that
hey there's footsteps over there
that's weird okay there's something over
there but this those are very clearly
footsteps
wait am i crazy those were clearly
footsteps not mine I just made those
okay all right whoa
hole in the ground oh boy
okay whoa I want to see what this hole
in the ground is all about yeah oh say
[ __ ] knew what he was doing before he
even came in here yeah yeah he kind of
did didn't he kind of a persuasive
[ __ ] like that yeah it's kind of what
he likes to do it's kind of what he use
it's more footprints I'm not crazy
you're crazy you're all crazy more
footprints I'm saying him whoa these
random holes oh that's scary
otherwise spirit and spirits like trip
to phobia scary
I agree we need Jojo but if I don't know
Lilly down just promise me you'll get it
Lillian Sebastian when this is all over
Mayra was planning on becoming the car
to let Lily leave I'm assuming maybe to
create a utopia for Lily and on the
Mobius would just ignore that swen it
happened when this place started to fall
apart
[Music]
peculiar and alrighty then I'll take it
that's weird why wait is just that
kitty hi kitty thank you for this Oh
another beer doesn't work anymore
well did my legs did a funny thing but
man this is this is some heavy [ __ ] this
is ridiculous
[Music]
I know there's like one more big
confrontation coming oh my shooting
gallery
nerves be having a poignant advise about
all this nurse and is so weird yeah I
don't think we're actually like dead dad
but limbo in this place would it mean
the same thing
you know functionally I'm afraid that
this will be the last time I can help
you oh I feel the end approaching me too
you've been here for me the whole time
both times maybe I've been with you
longer than that hey I don't want that
who are you I'm who I've always been
I'm who I'll always be I'm who you turn
to when you need inner strength and you
need me now more than ever and when this
is all over when this is all over you
won't need me again oh because this will
be over or because I'll be dead
the same answer applies either way
now let's get you ready why is the same
answer apply either way why does the
same plane why why why but why though
why would the same answer apply either
way all right why I have just enough to
be able to go for the extra life gauge
that's nice
I've already got the bullet cascade
really the only like big cost thing that
I could do would be that right I mean I
could go for like more stamina but in
the end what is that gonna do for me
besides just straight-up health I do
like I do like running away though I
really like running runnings like my
favorite thing ooh I really like running
yeah I've got enough health i'ma go food
running I love running running is like
super cool for me I really like running
and then I can get Tom Mouse yeah dude
this no I can't ah all right how about
that nah damn it
shouldn't have gotten running I'm how
about how about I'll go with this one
there we go thank you
I'm gonna leave this I'm gonna keep this
one red soup for sentimental reasons
that's all I know my office okay goodbye
All Right see ya goodbye I guess peace
and this might be it might be it yeah I
don't know some tells me there's more to
it but I think we're getting all the
answers eventually got I have no like
how am I gonna do I have to make assault
rifle stuff is that what I have to do
yeah yeah yeah whatever
upgrade my assault rifle for no reason
no reason at all right boom bolt charge
time oh oh
that's Andy why haven't I been doing
that oh that would have been that would
have been way better faster aiming would
have been great
oh that would have been lovely okay
let's man what else can we do we've got
all these bolts we got medical syringes
flame thrower fuel no assault rifle
cartridges you know what my not been
holding off on it the whole time why not
I buff it's upgraded 14 bullets not even
a full clip how are you how in the world
do you get a full clip of that thing you
don't I think is the answer you just
don't man open them to like a New Game+
you just get an unlimited ammo like
stream of bullets no one can stand in my
way to play this uneasy now the
nightmare was the perfect difficulty
setting it was really really well
balanced you know and if Reza for as
many times as I messed up you know it
still was quite forgiving even in the
worst of times but good good good stuff
good stuff nice tree I like that tree
that's a good tree that's a good tree
that's where a that's a good tree
[Music]
hello by protecting of my daughter
the power she commands you don't
understand no you don't understand what
I'll do to keep her safe close Byron you
kept her safe
that's not opening you're in danger that
sounded just like distance over there a
black spot
that just sounded like some weird audio
drama and I don't know why yeah just
like something out of Star Wars like no
you will die
[Music]
you know it's it's emotional like the
musical cues especially er are just like
very telling look it's a happy little
family
[Music]
Huayra is it you Sebastian
mm-hmm why are you fighting me Myra you
don't understand
this is our new home Lily will be safe
here happy
free from fear free from pain
no Myra
this isn't real
pain is part of real life and so is love
if she stays in here she won't live a
life free from fear because she won't be
living a life at all you don't
understand
the things they did to her I can protect
her no please let me take her out of
here
let's do it together we can be a family
again
[Music]
no I won't let anyone take her from me
well please Myra we still have time we
can leave I am NOT gonna leave Lily here
boy
I wonder if there's a way
please
tries must die don't do this
my god Myra you look so KRA Myra okay
also but also though okay that's
smooshed real splooshing
I don't want yourself you know I've
never liked your recipes I eat
not around drinking you know in a bar
somewhere god damn it well I'm dead you
know had you bet I shrugged it off well
here I go
hi I'm getting bullets way down honey
bunny Clank hi let's talk about this
pass honey please honey please please
honey
honey honey baby waiting flight in my
life
don't do that
[Music]
oh you're tough tough
oh wait BAM wait I gotta get the sniper
rifle out come on load up load up Oh
bullet cascade I don't want to do this
to you buyer I'm sorry it's not my
choice well gran there you go okay I
need a better shot
Oh bullet cascade
Oh
Oh winter weather let this work oh but
where are you where'd you put it
your picture [ __ ] went you sure oh
they're full of items they're full of
items it's okay you know I'm gonna heal
up I didn't know I didn't know if I was
gonna need it because I thought I was
gonna die
Oh shoulders Oh bulky bottled etiquette
okay well okay all right well Oh have
you lost weight oh geez
crouch dammit craps why why all right
thank you for that thank you big sister
I'm not using this this gun I should be
using my revolver for this classic bad
boy okay what have I got okay all right
one bullet left in that working bullets
there lots of that okay nice shoulders I
see what I'm supposed to do here all
right I'm trying to
sorry oh that's not good
no that's even worse that's even that's
much worse oh that's much worse oh that
okay that's bad regret I'm full of
regret so much regret I've got
oh I've got unlimited
Oh Myra you got an extra
IRA you know everyone always just you're
telling me this
[Music]
real oh wait no I'm out of bullets but
that one well here we go
I got a ye what are you aiming for there
sweetums
you please don't play how about you
don't you feel something coming you
stand up flip your hair back and forth
the worst thing literally the worst
thing you couldn't do anything worse
than this Oh
well out of that one for that lasted not
long all right time to good for the good
old fashioned boats I don't even know if
this is gonna reach you Oh miss that
wall don't move honey okay well you know
what I'm not gonna hit my target
oh that's a big ol ball oh god not more
of those things
no I'm hat clean third Jesus
well alright then that is extremely
inappropriate I just want to lay here
hang on got it
well that probably got me no apparently
not she's got a shoot up real quick hang
on honey
you know I have a bad drug problem I ran
right into that I ran right into that I
ran right into that
hang on wait honey sweetums love of my
life
and here we go okay wait hold on hold on
a second hair held on yeah damn
crippling addiction and all that
wait where to go read your glog oh
you're glowing
we're gonna go taking this
I can't go around the back way
Wow
what am I trying to do
what's the end objective
Oh
more of those things please maybe you
showed honey
yeah I got your back but you know all
every step of the way but maybe for this
one you should just kind of like not
test try old shotgun
Oh
honey honey I don't like this
no piace
unique but oh god oh god oh god oh
stamina
oh no not those no not the baby sacks oh
okay well I mean let me get out my
flamethrower like that
tock gambler chuckling from there
honey honey I love you
shit's got stuff sebastien ain't doing
so good yeah I know you have Lily Soto I
alright okay great honey that's
wonderful no not that one you [ __ ] I
was just reloading
[Music]
come on
with one bullet left with my last bullet
with my last bullets
oh so gross
the grossest thing never been grosser oh
nothing grosser baby you're still
beautiful maybe we should sleep in
separate beds constantly watch the seats
[Music]
Myra please
I'm so sorry I didn't want to
No
[Music]
couldn't control myself you did the
right thing
thank you I'm so glad you're alive
you have to take Lily
get her out of here
[Music]
I'm getting us all out of here come on
it's too far
believe me just get Lilly yeah man I
knew that me nah know I won't leave you
again
- I'm gonna execute like a fireman's
carry I don't know what kind of care
you're doing here but go I'll follow
I'll meet you there
Lily needs you now
please
come on like say ah like Samwise Gamgee
carrying Frodo up the mountain don't
don't do that
I could have chucked her over that wall
frickin game logic I would have carried
her oh oh oh okay alright I remember
there being a smoother way up that way
to the house but I see we can game logic
okay whatever
that's sad that is sad
yes almost there
yeah what about that was a perfectly
acceptable other am i right totally
forgot hey my read totally forgot lilies
in the house that's a perfectly good way
I see her right there Barra hey okay
fine whatever
ah boo scoffs oh [ __ ] one last oh there
we go
whoa we establish contact sir where is
he we can't get an exact location wait
the core has been located the marker is
approaching her excellent and struck the
marker and how to re-establish the core
I hate to be the bearer of bad news sir
but it's too late for that the
environment has taken too much damage
even with the core back in place total
collapse of Union is imminent so be it
we still have stem we can start again
but we need the core she's too valuable
to abandon I have the med team prepare
for core extraction
how much time depends on how fast he can
get her to the extraction point they're
close
shouldn't be long med team in place and
standing by
once extracted have the med team
terminate the marker he served his
purpose yes sir
kid call your man and give him
instructions well I guess this is it kid
kid did you hear me yeah I did
is that insubordination I'm sensing you
can't kill him yes we can and we will
once he's back in the real world he'll
become a liability now call him and tell
him where the extraction point is come
now kid he signed his death sentence the
moment he entered stim now do as I've
ordered or you'll be signing yours as
well no a shame that you'd attempt to
betray us I had such hope for you yeah I
have such hope in the form of a bullet
for you I've got a very hopeful bullet
here sweet oh yeah
sweet roll all right I can do this
should taking your shot
[Applause]
excuse you oh geez oh oh oh okay slam
slam okay holder burrow
you guys can't all these days they can't
hit me bump us up reload the got damn it
it's the controller's broken
[ __ ] grab a cup pop your ad back up why
am I willing Bob come on I had that shot
my reloaded
I'm bad at this huh mister can I move I
can't move I literally see all the
bullet holes right next to his head yeah
that's that's my bad yeah
that's my bad hang on I got this
I'll be right back up please come on it
stop wiggle off why is it the most
Wibbly one how is this guy not dead I've
so many bullet holes there we go right
by his head when I'm there I want to go
over to that wall and inspect like the
19 bullets right by his head
[Music]
when it doesn't come to soup she's not a
soup expert uh she must be upstairs
Willie Willie gosh she's got to be
upstairs Lilly are you down here
Lilly I think she's upstairs any other
secrets
oh you find the design of this toy
deeply unsettling but something compels
you to pick it up you don't want to
carry it around but you said to keep it
in your room for safekeeping he's gonna
be like a five nights at Freddy's
situation where everything actually is
explained in the toys is that what it is
okay man why do I lock so many on my
doors here Lilly Lilly here we go that's
a weird way to sleep
Lily my sweet little girl
it's me Lily I'm here
is it really Hugh Shh
it's really me I'm here to take you home
you mean we're not home now baby I'll be
won't be soon so tired go back to sleep
when you wake up we'll be safe again
Milo you're there oh you made it got her
come on let's get the hell out of here
I'm sorry Sebastian
I can't yes you can
I'll carry both of you if I have to but
I'm not mobius has to be stopped
[Music]
screw Mobius we've lost too much time to
them already we can get away just the
three of us we'll go someplace where
they'll never find us there's nowhere to
hide
they're everywhere Lily will always be
in danger unless I destroy them okay
fine I'll wait one small business comes
as a work that wastes Sebastian it can
only be done from inside stem is more
than just this place all of Mobius are
connected to it via the chips in their
heads
once I assume the power of the Corps I
can transmit a signal just as Union
collapses a signal that can take Mobius
down once and for all we're finally
together again there's no other choice
this is part of the plan it always has
been
I'm sorry Myra
Shh just promise to take care of the
little one never let her forget how much
her mother loved her
[Music]
so much I want to say to you
I've been watching you all this time I
know how you've suffered what they did
to you what I did to you you didn't ask
for any of this you've been into hell
twice for it it's time for you to leave
now to live the life
it was taken from you
[Music]
I love you Myra
I love you too
both of you that's why I'm doing this
but there's no more time you have to go
now
[Music]
they're there they're the [ __ ] okay
I said hey do you guys got bigger heads
than the other guys that's why I'm
hoping for a poke your head out again
you don't got me pinned down you know
nice wait dude I think maybe your cover
is a little cool clipping your cover oh
there's these guys got really armored
skulls
whoa oh he moved up I was mistaken but
if I just really BLAP as hard as I can
black good think I got unlimited ammo I
see your arm there this way okay hey on
Sebastian it's me probably Lily coming
for you your gum maybe no okay all right
okay I can't do that my god those aren't
numbers
whoo Kidman's up where Kimmons better
than sebastian ever was uh i think it's
cuz her specialty isn't soup it's
bullets which is the very clear
distinction here what are you doing kid
your actions will only result in your
death you must know this you has such
potential you could have amassed such
power and now you choose to throw it all
away why after all you've seen all
you've done why the crisis of conscience
now is it for the detective
for the child
[Music]
it's for me
think about what you're doing kid
stem is needed imagine it a unified
consciousness for all mankind no more
Wars
no more disparity
okay no going back down
then hope you were right Myra okay maybe
you never know these things are weird
like that so we'll see what happens
where's Jojo that's what I want to know
no Chipman I've got her where do I go
the Meier is staying behind you know why
okay I'm counting on you to bet okay
here I go
here we go one final journey for so
again like a fireman's carry might be
better and I'll just saying that okay Oh
shining bright light light bright
shining bright oh that's not good oh my
gosh look so bad just aggravate let go
come on you stupid piece of [ __ ] ah God
guides start something ow scare
doosh right boy
well unions seen better days
oh please please come on
[ __ ] a girl doesn't aggravate it dad
like
a stuck in traffic what
like put on old telemarketer the fire
alarm keeps going up one more time there
about how not they're late to stop this
if you do I promise to oh that's
wonderful otherwise skills the
punishment for your betrayal will be
legendary what Barney Stinson I'm going
to be legendary all right legendary for
taking you down
a world without choice if in a utopia
a hive mind only works with a queen that
controls it join the third I will guess
what there's a third choice
and that's [ __ ] you yeah oldest
it's a shame to have to lose you like
this vid ma boy you thought that I was
just flying by the seat of my pants here
I took my chip out three days funny
come on oh wise ponies funny oh here it
comes
this is one
Sebastian we're almost out of time
just shootie a lot of bang Bang's no oh
do I have to do this one alright okay I
got it don't oh here we go I don't have
to do [ __ ] I needed a subtitle for that
yes
just dive headfirst into the mirror just
dive just shove your ball face in their
own just scoot back jump backwards now
would be the time
get plenty of time Sebastian Sebastian
you had so much time
but gets behind them close appointments
die first
go
sure okay that for that
sebastian i love you both now you'll be
safe
looks like a skull it looked like a
skull right there
oh heck yeah these transitions are sick
Oh Julie you did it my rod I knew you
would
here we go I'm ready let's blame lamb
this
Oh
[Music]
take it easy Sebastian you're safe now
really where's Lily I need your help
getting her out stand over there
she better not be a brain in a jar I
really hope she's not a brain in the jar
oh no all right she a brand in a jar
[Music]
freshest soup oh good oh great she's not
a brand in the jar okay good good good
good good
good to know open on its own sebastian
alright
[Music]
well Hugh yep yes Lily it's really me
I I was having the worst nightmare Shh
I know that
but your weight down the nightmares over
there's nothing to be scared of anymore
it really is isn't it I'm not still
inside there just thinking I'm it really
is over thanks to Myra come on let's get
the hell out of here
all right
I don't trust it I don't trust this
I don't trust it Tom's not right here
that's not right
this oh okay we go then huzzah but wait
a gun I think there's something at the
end of the credits here we'll get
through the credits no but I just wanted
to say oh this has been such a fun
experience I really am glad I really am
glad that you all enjoyed it so much
yeah
and just wait for one more moment if you
got to go I totally understand but just
listen for one this thing I'm not gonna
end this just yet I'm gonna wait till
the end of the credits but also thank
you everybody for joining me on this
like livestream adventure and I know a
lot of you guys have been watching it
like after the livestream has been
posted and I tried to make it as similar
to a normal let's play as possible but
with that live aspect to it the the
lessons that I learned from doing these
live streams in the morning is one it's
it's a bit too early so I'm probably not
gonna be doing live streams at 8:00 a.m.
every day and the other lesson is that I
love doing both live-action stuff and
gaming stuff I don't want to just do
series I want to do the one offs again -
but I do love the live aspect of playing
games I don't know exactly like where I
want it to go but I know that I want to
do live streams like probably more
towards the afternoon of where I am NOT
in the evenings I want to do like
afternoon live streams just because I
love my mornings and I love being able
to do that Oh music yeah that's pretty
good
but it's just like it's really cool and
I'm so grateful that you guys join me on
this adventure but also I don't even
know if I'm gonna be streaming on
YouTube like there's there's other live
streaming platforms that I want to try
there's there's like twitch and there's
mixer which interests me a lot so I
don't really know all I know is that I
really am appreciative of you guys
joining me on this adventure and I'm so
glad that I was able to play this game
with you guys and in a collaborative
effort like this and just being here
like all together and enjoying the
experience all of one and you guys
helping me out live
and that's really really cool so I want
to carry that through and I want to
carry it onto more stuff that I do in
the future and I just don't know when
and where but keep an eye out on my
social media I'll let you guys know then
or you know it sounds cliche at this
point but that Bell icon if you want to
get a notification every time that I go
live or I post a video put that one
there and just thank you guys so much
for being here with me like it's super
cool now we're gonna get to the end of
this stream or we're gonna get to the
end of this credits because I'm willing
to bet there is something else there
yeah a lot of you guys are like Jojo
where's Jojo exactly that's why I'm
thinking me and Kidman are about to have
a conversation about Jojo maybe maybe
maybe there's gonna be like some DLC for
wow that's pretty loud ham let me turn
that down
that's hot hot hot hot shot there we go
hush hush hush hush hush okay
box box that's what I'm thinking right
like evil within three maybe it's Joe
Joe's escape out of it because there's
this like stem underworld that they keep
talking about right right like this
whole stem thing like what does that
mean what does that mean the main world
of stem like like like falls apart but
what else is there what else is there
it's either TLC or it's gonna be like
evil within three is gonna be about Joe
Joe I'm excited for it that's what I
want
yes yes but Iike I want to see I want
evil within three to be like the super
unbelievably cliched buddy cop one it's
like it's not even horror anymore it's
just like I get in stem like I dive bomb
with my parachute explosions behind me
like glass breaking like aah Joe Joe's
there like with like a minigun Joe Joe's
been fighting people for three years
straight and I'm just like Joe Joe Wow
don't you hate these late shift is like
I won't wonder when you get here and
then it all gets back together and then
ruvik comes in with like sunglasses like
big cliche you will fill in all back
again Allah you thought I was dead it'll
take more than squishing my brain to
kill me in puts on sunglasses and then
he pulls out two like boosie's and just
like that's how it goes that's why I
want evil
the tree to be like yeah oh yeah we
didn't really answer the question of
what Lala lady was all about either
that's a weird thing or we didn't really
answer the question of like why Mayra
had those weird orange worm things in
her eyeballs or why she became like
corrupted in the first place if she
couldn't control herself what was
controlling her you know what I mean
what's Lala lady all about you know what
I mean
you know what I mean you know what I
mean yeah you know what I mean okay I
don't know if I skip these um if I skip
these credits is it going to miss the
after credits sequence can you guys let
me know if it does I want to evil within
three JoJo's escape yeah that's yeah but
if you can you guys let me know if I
skip the credits is gonna is it gonna
miss the end credits scene or is it not
a little little adieu
yes no no yes wait hang on I got to
reach a consensus here
Lala lady was your regret and guilt
maybe they know it won't skip it
yeah sure Lowell what okay you're saying
yes and no at the same time it will it
won't skip it it's possible it's not a
South yet sir don't skip uh it doesn't
skip don't do it it does what it won't
skip the scene it won't skip it I guess
it don't skip okay
yes maybe ah here we go oh there we go
perfect right
[Music]
ah here's a doll of your mom just just
as good
[Music]
alright see ya ok see ya this is a
little surreal the music is a little
ominous
[Music]
aha
Oh
[Music]
ooh
what
Oh
what classic mode difficulty has been
unlocked abandon all hope ye who enter
here
what sixty thousand green gel oh hell
yeah
unlock the professional outfit if only
those days could have gone on forever
The Drifter out you got knocked down but
you get up again the classic outfit ah
being in here again you getting up at
remember the lesson the meh you know in
case you ever wanted to carry around a
tiny cannon brass knuckles
maybe you already have a bunch of
weapons but now you are a weapon what
you like the ultimate reward a cinematic
[Laughter]
yeah wait wait ah
well why did I save that is that for
like future stuff oh well what well hang
on now okay how do I turn on
wait where's cinematic yeah hang on
we're cinematic where's that how general
is in general Oh display where is it
where's the center where's the scented
letterbox there we go gimme that was the
first game old letterbox see I can't
remember
hang on wait yeah okay hang on new game+
and they select a difficulty equal log
to the original completed clear slave
you sue is yeah wait okay hang on you
can't do classic mode uh if you're new
game+ ah but I want the cannon I want
the gun okay my favorite reward from the
Dead Space series was the foam finger
like the bang bang bang bang you would
blow everyone away so good oh man I'm
not gonna do classic mode wait hat okay
everyone hold on to your horses hey I
might not be done yet I might not be
done I might not be done
oh come on skip skip yep all right [ __ ]
what boring boring your god come on skip
yep I just want to get to the cannon oh
wait I'd have to get all the way to
chapter three D at that do this
chapter one no no no no this is not
happening this is not happening
oh yeah yeah even within three is gonna
be Lily versus Rubik's oh it said just
the battle of the brains really just put
some more sunglasses like three pairs of
sunglasses and pulls out yeah but what
about Joe Joe Kidman said that we were
gonna talk about that maybe if you beat
the game on like classic mode maybe if
you actually beat it like again on
classic mode you could do that but for a
second I thought that was like weather
frozen corpses it's so cinematic you're
right guys look at this letterbox
oh my god it's the most cinematic oh my
I can't even believe it look how oh it's
amazing
Oh looky loo at this how did this happen
oh okay all right
ba ba ba ba yeah where is Joe Joe I'm
willing to bet that if you if you do if
you do look up something about the end
credits scenes in classic mode
maybe maybe there'll be something maybe
there'll be something maybe I don't know
though I don't know I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that one
all right hello Lily are you in here
skipping oh there we go skip skip skip
skip you're awake
gab come on great oh I just want to get
the kit you know it's not worth it yeah
sorry
well I saw the cinematic nature that's
really what I wanted the cannon was just
gonna be a bigger bang bang but anyway
so that is all for the evil within -
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope there's DLC to this game I really
do I enjoyed the previous the first
games DLC a lot it was really good and
you could see how the DLC kind of
influenced where the game was gonna go
in the sequel they learned a lot of
lessons the developer this game is
really really they know what they're
doing like this is really good it's
really good really good really good ah
it's good so hopefully there'll be some
answers that come up later but once
again thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for joining me on
this experience thank you everybody for
being here with me on these live
adventures once again like I said before
I'm probably not gonna do them in the
mornings I'm not gonna do 8 a.m. streams
again but I do want to do a lot more
gaming content and I do want to post
some cool stuff I want to do more of the
edited like gaming videos I probably
want to take like take the opportunity
to do things live and play with you guys
and then turn them into something even
bigger and better than I could hope for
in like not necessarily always being a
highlight reel or a compilation thing
but you know I want to play all the
games that I've always played like I've
never stopped loving games and also I
want to do all the cool stuff like the
van videos that I've been doing and
that's very important to me so thank you
everybody so much for letting me do that
it's been super fun just the past two
weeks of playing this game and learning
and doing a lot of cool videos and I'm
loving it more than ever and and I love
that you guys can see it and I'm so
happy that you guys are here for me so
there's gonna be a lot more content
unfortunately today I won't have a video
it up at noon I have
Tyler's parents are in town and I
promised that I was gonna go out and we
were gonna spend some time together
because they're only gonna be in town
for a few more days so I'm gonna go hang
out with them more videos coming at you
tomorrow and it'll be super fun so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know you think that right there in
the comments right and and keep an eye
out for what I'm gonna be doing streams
later I'm gonna be trying out different
platforms seeing what I like the best
seeing what's best for you if YouTube
does end up being the best one then
that's what I must stick with but I
probably not but I will be posting
gaming content to YouTube more than I
ever have so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye guys